Hey, what's going on is bill burns
time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast and yeah,
just checking in on you.
You liked up.
That was my imitation of a car with no
balls going from first gear to second
gear.
Ah,
well actually would start in
first. So that's, it's sec.
My impression of a car with no balls
going from second to third gear.
That's what it is.
Sorry,
I just wanted you to know every fucking
person out there listening to this.
I'll right. We get the joke bill. God,
speaking of jokes,
I'm going to be at the hard rock cafe
tonight in Fort Lauderdale, Florida.
Huh?
Jesus Christ.
How many sexual harassments can happen
just on the fucking beaches out here?
Good Lord.
I mean,
is that story ever going to end every
time you think they got the last guy?
I mean that, that down to like fucking,
they're going to have to cook snow.
How was making bacon and all of a sudden
I felt these heads and I was like,
wait,
is that squid still alive?
Turned around and all I saw
was orange and freckles.
Oh Christ. Meanwhile, we're
spending $1 billion a month.
I finally just,
I dunno,
we're spending $1 billion a month fighting
people that train on a fucking jungle
gym. I just, I, it's like,
it's like throwing $1 billion.
If you have a beehive on the
side of your fucking house,
you got to get rid of the
bees. Absolutely. You're
going to beat those bees,
but you're not gonna have
any fucking money. Sorry.
Anyways, plowing ahead
here. Um, by the way,
I am in a week to week two
of 'em my Invisalign and I
just keep these fuckers in
cause I want this to be over as soon
as possible. Actually really like him.
I'm kind of used to it and now
my bite is totally fucking off.
I don't know what the fuck's going on with
me, but I'm, I'm, I'm riding this out,
but I only take these things out to eat.
You know,
I've already lost the little case. You
know that you're supposed to carry him in.
They give you a blue one that's
blue and the one that's red,
the blue one you supposed
to take out in public,
the other one's red and that
means stop leave it at home.
Okay.
So you know me, you don't know
me. You think you know me,
but you know a lot of what you
think you know about me is right.
So I've already fucking lost, uh, my, uh,
my container here,
but I got this container of icebreakers
mints and I noticed that their gum
container is the exact same fucking
shape as the other containers.
So I just figured rather than
going to, you know, fuck,
I lost my container.org,
Oregon,
you know, ordering another one. Um, I'll
just use the icebreaker mid thinking.
That's probably stupid.
Then I'll think it's governmental.
Shake it and I won't hear any gum
in there and I'll throw it out. Oh,
well we'll see.
You know,
I think Alannis Morissette said it best
when she said you have man, you learn.
Um
Huh.
Jesus Christ. What an album that
was. Huh? My God. Good Lord.
You know, looking back now, looking
back at that album, it's just like a,
I think you,
you need to go take like an MMA class.
Yeah.
And if you actually learned how to beat
the shit out of somebody who wouldn't be
so fucking emotional,
you could just be like a guy,
you know, sitting there all fucking
stoic at the end of the bar,
stewing in your anger, listening
to James Brown, the big payback.
Fantasizing about what the fuck
you want to do. You could do that.
Well, you can be like, you know,
freaking people out with the Goddamn
Ukulele sitting there going, hey,
hey, hey, hey,
wait, let us he's, he found somebody else.
He's not coming back. All right. Just,
you going to have to accept this. What
the fuck happened on my computer screen?
Yeah, that's, that's, that's computed
for go fuck is, oh, it's back.
Look, goes back, back again. Um, anyways,
a couple of announcements.
Uh, Patrice O'Neal benefit.
February 20th makes a great
Christmas gift. Come on people,
you getting down to the fucking why
it's December 14th, man. Hanukkah is
already three days in. I got to give it,
I got to give it up to fucking mainstream
people for putting up really going all
out with the minorities.
This year I was down the Improv.
They had a GI at fucking Christmas tree
in this little fucking piece of Shit
Menorah. You know what I
mean? It was fucking nuts.
As little piece of shit just
sitting on the fucking piano.
But there was two days late. That was
last night, right. With two nights ago,
we were in the fourth day.
On the fourth day of Hanukkah,
my Jewish friend gave to me a piece
of Shit Menorah from the Improv.
Um, four days. Then I came
to the hard rock cafe.
They've got a couple of lights
fucking lit up there. I had no idea.
It took the red eye in, uh, flew in on a
fucking virgin airlines, which by the way,
I don't feel comfortable
flying that fucking airline
cause I think they put more
money into their fucking seatbelt song
video then they did on the actual plane.
Cause every time I get on that fucking
plane, you know me, I'm a fancy guy.
I spent 20 years in the back of the
fucking plane. I ain't going back. Okay?
What I have to pay, okay. I want to
be breathing down the pilot's neck.
That's how I fly commercial.
I want to know when one of them
gets up to go the bathroom.
That's where the fuck I want to fly.
All right?
That's my one diva
demand in this business.
I fly up front. That's it. Um, I'm
not, I spent 20 years back then.
I'm not fucking going back there.
You know, I might, you know,
you never know what happens in your
career, but if I end up back there,
I swear to God I'm packing like a rock
star when they go on tour for fucking two
years where they bring one pair of pants,
two tee shirts and a toothbrush.
That's the way I'm packing.
I'm going to start dressing all in black.
Like George Carlin had Johnny Cash.
I've already worked it out.
If I fucking go back there,
okay,
if I have to go to the back of the plane
again, I'm going Vegan, I'm doing yoga.
I'm to become this skinny
as I possibly fucking can.
And then I'm bringing this little fucking
nap sack with me because that's all
the back of the plane is.
It's just stress. Fuck.
How fat is the fat fuck sitting
next to me going to be, fuck,
is it going to be fucking
head space? Let me, sorry.
Overhead compartment space
for my little fucking bag.
That's all it is.
The whole fucking thing is that fuck
is the person next to me going to be
snoring. Fuck. Am I going to
sit next to the bathroom? Fuck,
I'm in the back of the plane.
After awhile I got sick
of it after a while.
Freckles got sick of it and I just
said, fuck this. How much is it?
I don't give a shit. Throw it
on the fucking card. So anyway,
so I said, I'm sitting up
front. All right. And uh,
he never threw flew virgin airlines.
If they have this fucking
music video that they did,
which I get doing the announcements, you
know, there are emergency exits are here.
This is fucking there. Don't do
this. Don't try to open any windows.
While the plane's in flight, you
know, whatever the fuck they say,
don't try to let your shoes on fire.
So they were like, this is
boring. Where the hip airline,
we have all this aquarium lighting here.
You know, let's, we liked the plane.
Like everyone's going to get a hand
job right after they fucking take golf.
Right. How long before they get
shit for their sexual harassment.
Fucking lighting. Yeah. Everyone
should smell like Cologne.
That's the way it's fucking lit on
those planes. And uh, so they, they,
they will make decide they decided out
of the bucket blue to make this music
video.
Okay.
To like give you the announcements
and when I tell you this fucking,
it feels like it's 15
fucking minutes long. Yeah.
It's so fucking like loud.
And then everybody's doing that, you
know, Post Christina Aguilera singing.
Yeah.
You know where you got to hit
every note on the fucking scale.
Every three words like Christina
Aguilera singing, row, row, row, your
doing that fucking Jesus.
Like you tickle and a cat
and it's not enjoying it.
I'm not saying she's a bad singer,
but it's like I get it.
Jesus Christ,
Jesus Christ.
So they have all of that fucking uh,
you know those fucking
women that when they sing,
they got a point where their voices go
in. Like it's like I get, I'm tone deaf,
but you know, I don't need you to
be doing like a fucking, you know,
leaving breadcrumbs of where the fuck
you going on the music scale. Okay.
I could tell by the way
my eardrums are vibrating.
You're getting up into
the stratosphere there.
MMM.
So this fucking song
goes on forever and ever.
And just when you think it's over it,
then they do this stupid robot part.
I don't even know what they're saying.
My grandpa painted bed, bed, bed, bed,
bed, Eh, Eh,
oh my God. Oh my God, I'm going
to light my shoes on, fire up.
This fucking thing doesn't end.
So,
and then what happens is I try
to put my headphones on, right?
And then you just say, excuse me. See
here, nine 11, support the troops.
Could you take your fucking
headphones off? Fortunately,
last night they didn't make me do that
cause I took the red eye in and the uh,
the stewardesses were were cool. Whatever
the fuck you supposed to call them,
flight attendees.
Um,
they were cool and they didn't make
me take the fucking things off,
but she's as fuck.
And then meanwhile they stay,
spend like fucking $1 million
on this goddamn thing. Um,
I'm all these fucking Waylon divas
and robot people in all of this shit.
And they then they take talks up in the
boring announcements that only took like
45 seconds.
Now it's like a 10 minute God damn video.
MMM.
And they spent all that fucking money
on that and I have never been on virgin,
flown up front and after I reclined the
seat, had the seat go a back up again.
The fucking stewardess always has flight
attendees always has to come over and
fucking windy to fly.
Any 10 year over year always has to come
and open that middle part and there's
some sort of secret fucking lever to
pull it up. So then that makes me think,
okay,
if this is what's going on with the seats,
like what's going on with the engine?
Um, all right. I was catastrophizing.
All right, but that's something
you do when you're on a plane.
Okay.
You know,
cause like when we were taken off,
it was vibrating a little bit too much.
I was just thinking like, you know,
it's lax. It's like, ah, fuck. What
if we crash into the ocean right now?
And even worse,
what if we have a really good pilot?
Like sully who doesn't have the decency
to just fucking knows it in and kill us
all instantly. Now we've got to
float. They're waiting for sharks.
The fucking Itas cause it's nighttime.
You know what I mean? During the day.
I want selly. Alright. At night, you know,
I don't know what I want. I want just,
just knows it forward. All right. Uh,
we don't get enough fucking
thrust to get lift here.
Speak for myself. I had a good one.
Yeah, just go straight down in. Um,
okay.
But anyways, uh, Jesus Christ,
I went to go buy a fucking magazine
before I got on the flight. My God,
everything was so fucking depressing.
Do you know the cover of Newsweek?
They got a picture of the earth,
like waterless saying that's what like
the future is going to be and it's just
like,
who in the fuck would buy that?
And I'm going to say I'm going to sit
there and read that and then do what?
Think about my [inaudible], my daughter
over there in, in some waterless world.
I Dunno. I think, uh,
you know, I mean I just don't
understand that, how that helps me.
And I also don't think that that's the
direction we're going to go in as much as
everybody's flapping their arms and
screaming, yelling and all of that shit.
There is some good news out there about
all of this type of stuff, you know?
Cause you know why I know this.
You know,
I know this because I'm getting sick of
all this fucking negative news and all,
you know the fucking iPhone now
they want you to fingerprint,
which I'm not sure doing so coincidentally
enough, all of a sudden my phone,
you know,
cause I didn't finish air quotes,
setting it up by giving a
fucking cell phone company.
Okay,
whoever the fuck it
is. Um, my fingerprint,
it's like, why would I give you my,
why would I give you my fingerprint?
You fucking assholes. First of all, I
love, oh apple keeps acting like this.
This epidemic of people getting
their phone's broken into.
Like if you set it down,
somebody's going to figure
out your 46 digit code.
Like they're fucking Christopher
Walken in the dead zone.
All they gotta do is touch,
shake your fucking hand, and
you're like, it's one, two,
three, four. Right? You're like,
fuck, he can get into my phone.
I've never had my phone
broken into because somebody
knew my fucking pass code.
I'm sure somebody has gone in another way,
sitting in the fucking,
you know their house.
I don't know how the fuck they do it,
but I know my thumbprint and showing
my face or whatever the fuck it is,
these assholes want from me.
Um,
oh fucking uh, Billy Apocalypto
here. I think I'm, I'm, I'm,
I dunno, I've made this claim before,
but I think I'm going to do it.
I might think I'm going to go,
but I'm going to go flip phone,
MP three player because the only reason
why I really liked the smartphone is I
loved it. All my music is on
there. I really enjoy that.
So if I was in the
cell phone fucking market,
what I would do is I would make flip
phones that could fucking carry the music,
you know,
flip phone slash MP three player and
I'm throwing that out there right now so
people can write me. Oh, actually
there is a phone like that.
It's called the MP three
player. Flippy. Uh,
it's made by sprint or whatever.
The fuck it, I'm going to go,
I think I'm going to do that.
And then when I'm on the road,
I'll just Skype on my computer. I
guess I'll do that fucking shit. Um,
speaking of which, by the way,
I've gotten into like fucking,
I downloaded this James Brown
album a long time ago. That was a,
let me see if I can find it.
Of course now I'm not going to be able to
find the fucking thing, go into library
type in his name. But
anyways, it's at this point,
even if you're a casual fan
of James Brown, you know,
they basically on the radio and
in movies and all of this shit,
all they do is they just, they,
they play like the same fucking,
you know,
the same five fucking songs,
20 songs.
You know,
Dan Patrick got a brand new bay.
They play that gut feel good.
The same ones. You got to get his fucking
albums where you can hear all the,
all the beside once. Um, and I've been,
you know, I bought this book,
this Trump book the other day,
which I'm just getting into it and it
looks like it's going to be one of the
best,
uh,
drunk books I've seen in a while
called the breakbeat Bible.
And it kind of breaks down. Um, we're,
although all the rappers and everybody,
like all the songs that they sample
all those drum brakes and then the kids
would dance to them, which, why are
they will call breakdancers all of that,
all that shit that the white guy like
me didn't know til I watched a couple of
Netflix documentaries and
I watched a drum cover of,
I forget what the fuck I was watching.
I think the funky drummer,
like someone was showing me all the
ghost notes and stuff and said that they,
that they had a good breakdown
of it. And this, this, this book,
the breakbeat Bible,
which I got.
And then it came with the little
fucking MP three CD. I'm like,
what the fuck is that?
How I do this?
And now all of a sudden I'm getting a flip
phone, an MP, three player. So anyways,
um,
I would highly recommend checking out
like some of all of his shit and like
alternate takes and stuff. Uh, what the
fuck is the name of it? Now, of course,
they're not going to show me the
name of the fucking thing are they?
It's called make it funky.
Uh, for God's sakes.
I even like it shit in like
the 70s when it's kind of over.
Like everybody's moved on to like disco
and shit and everybody's ripped him off
and stuff and he's
still fucking like ACDC.
He's just doing what the fuck he
does. All right, let me see. Yeah,
make it funky.
Dash the big payback.
1971 to 1975 a I get that album.
I would download that shit.
Yeah, listen to that man.
It's fucking incredible.
And um,
oh man, I don't know. Anyway,
so I'm, I'm, I'm fucking, I'm already
thinking of drums, drum songs.
I want to fucking be able to
play. Uh, speaking of which,
I think I'm doing the goddamn
comedy jam next month at the Roxy.
I think it's January 22nd. Is
that a Tuesday? Is that a Tuesday?
Let's see here. Let's
see here. It's a Monday.
It's either the 22nd or the 23rd.
Um,
in the fucking Song Josh
Adam Meyers wants to do,
cause I want to do this fucking song
and it's just like, it's like, dude,
I want to go there and have a good time.
I don't want my fucking
arms to be fallen off.
He wants to do this fucking iron maiden.
So I'm one of those Clive burnt ones.
We either your arms or your foot
is going to fucking fall off.
Like I'd love to do a cover
of the prisoner, but that one,
when he does those for bass drums in a
fucking row, on a good day I can get that.
But in front of a room full of people
where I'll be in my head be like,
oh my God, don't tighten up. I
know it's just going to fuck it.
I'm going to shit the bed.
I'll pay like two and a half and then the
whole band is going to look back at me
and smiling like, yeah,
yeah, just a comedian. Um,
I don't want to go through that. You
know, I want to live the lie. Like,
I'm actually,
I couldn't like light in myself that
I could have done this professionally.
That's all you want. Audio. Hobby. Right.
Okay.
You don't give a fuck about
getting compliments that your job,
it's all about your fucking hobby.
Yeah.
Somebody's appreciating that you'd
be a goddamn neurosurgeon. Oh my God.
I can't believe the way you replace
my brain. I just want to thank you.
And the guy's not even thinking that he's
not even fucking, you know what I mean?
Not even hearing it.
It's not even listening to you.
Then somebody comes walking
in and you're like, Hey doc,
did you put this ship in this bottle?
That's amazing. And the guys, same guys,
just like
my wife doesn't support
me and says I'm bad at it.
Um, anyways, I fucked up people.
I went to a Goddamn cvs and I bought
the wrong fucking disposable fucking
raises. I should've gone to dollar
shave club and I didn't. I just,
in a spur of the moment,
I might get some cheap razors.
I can need to shape my fucking head
when I'm on the road and you can't my
experience,
you cannot have three blades when you
shave your head because you're going to
hack up the back of your head.
You need the two blades.
So now I got like three packs of
these fucking thing. Thanks. And um,
so next time I do a show in La,
if I remember I'm bringing them,
I'm just going to give them
away to somebody in the
crowd cause I'm not fucking
fucking throw them out.
Um,
Jesus Christ too.
I always getting patient in the end
when I do the back of my head after you
shave your head,
then you got to go over it one more time
to make sure he didn't miss anything.
I just, and that's the time I cut my head.
Just go quick, quick, quick, quick, quick,
quick, quick, quick. Ah Fuck. And then
it's just like Jesus Christ. You know,
I got like three hacks in the back
of my head. You know, I'm fortunate.
It's on the back of my head.
So people come out to my,
this week I'll be very stiff.
You know, just sort of walking
so I can't show the back of
my goddamn head. All right,
what am I talking about here? We're 20
minutes in Jesus Christ. Just like that.
Let's fucking a, let's do the, uh,
let's do a little bit of
fucking advertising here.
All right. Where am I man
crates? Everybody. Uh,
it's hard to pick out the perfect gift,
but all too easy to get it totally wrong.
Introducing man, create stock. Come
the surest way to find awesome gifts.
Guys will love guaranteed.
This isn't a lane cheese of the month
club with the or a new tie man crate
offers awesome gifts for every type of
guy from the rugged outdoorsman to the
sportsman attic and everything in between.
I'm never doing a podcast again with
these fucking Invisalign's in become this
mealy mouth jackass. Um, like
the whiskey appreciation crate,
which they sent me and I'm on the
fucking wagon. You know what I mean?
Would you send a former fucking crackhead
Illumina? So on a statement of crack,
is there such a thing?
You know, like they have,
the blue methods are better cracks.
You know like a keynote red,
white.
They have all the races have
keenwah, right? African American,
like the whiskey appreciation crate with
the personalized laser etch decanter
and glasses for his favorite
drink and the grill master crate.
What they brass knuckle meat tenderizer
for the wife beat out there and a cast
iron smoker box.
I already know what they're going to say.
Could you please not make a reference to
the wife beaters people? No, I'm joking.
Does Man Craig,
did they support beating your wife?
Okay.
Is this something we
should be offended by?
That's all shit that's on the
sidebars. Oh, that's okay.
That would be like an article.
An actual article on the Huffington
post has fucking low rent costs.
Just go to [inaudible] dot com pick the
perfect crate and choose your delivery
date when his man crate arrived.
So you'll be the envy of every guy in
the room as he prize that bad boy open
with his own laser.
Engrave Crowbar a,
they have thousands of five
star reviews in every man.
Craig comes with their
high five guarantee.
Okay.
Wow. They're really steering into the
fucking mouth. Breathing guy here.
Got My own fucking crowbar. All
in the holidays. Call to action.
Um,
go to man crate.com/burn to get five
births to get 5% off your order.
How do you mispronounce your own name?
They don't offer this discount
anywhere else. That's 5% off, man.
crates.com/burr man
crates.com/burr crates is c,
r. A. T. E. S if you're dumb
like me. All right, tipsy yells,
everybody a,
are you going to a Christmas party and a,
you don't have a good opening line.
Would it be great if you just walked in
with an ugly sweater and everybody would
just accept you and give you a big
hug and you could finally relax?
You know,
dry. You're sweaty. Palms off on your
own fucking ugly Christmas sweater. Well,
thank God for tipsy elves.
You know why?
Because everyone needs an ugly
Christmas sweater this time of year.
If you want bragging rights for
the most talked about sweater,
your Christmas parties listen up while
you're shopping for your ugly sweater.
Checkout to the, you know, what she
want to do is you got to get, like,
if you really want to have
the most talked about sweater,
you'd get a Harvey Weinstein ugly
Christmas sweater that would shoot two and
you'd get them like, you
know, with his hands,
like he was about ready to grab somebody.
You know,
I wonder if they offer one of those
or bill Cosby dropping some shit and
somebody drink while you're shopping for
your ugly sweater. Checkout the
other holiday attire for yourself.
How about Hitler blown his brains out
wearing a Santa hat or as a gift like
adult onesies.
They even sell wild and crazy ski
suits for you skiers out there,
tipsy yells has hundreds of Christmas
sweater designs that are like nothing.
You've ever seen a John Denver,
you know post-crash.
They're not the for the faint of heart,
I guess they're saying ugly, not
horrific. I'm going horrific. All right,
let me dial it back to
ugly. All right, the,
you have the back of my head right now.
I'm on a Christmas sweater for men.
Three piece Christmas suits, interactive
sweaters, beer pong, corn hole,
and hilarious holiday teas
for women holiday, letting
leggings, sweater dresses,
and cozy adult onesies,
specific sizing for men and
women so everyone can get
the perfect fit right now.
My listeners get 20% off tipsy elves.com
when you use my code burr at checkout.
Uh, that's Twynam. How about
a prison rape with elves?
20% off of anything you order on site
shop now so you have the best selection to
choose from. And, and in time for
your ugly Christmas sweater party,
go to tipsy elves.com enter my code
Burr at checkout to get 20% sitewide
discount. That's tipsy elves.com
and my code burr. All right,
two more to go. Um, dollar
shave club. Everybody.
Dollar Shave Club's ships.
Amazing raises for a few bucks.
I have to get back into this club.
All right, look what happened.
I left the club and now I'm
hacking up the back of my head. Um,
what you might know,
not know I have a hack head right now.
Well you might not know is that dollar
shave club also has products for pretty
much everything you need in the bathroom.
I don't think to say they actually
have it for pretty girls to shave your
impeccable Bush with dollar shave club,
bodywash shampoo, Hair Gel, lip balm,
everything at the store.
There are too many options and you can't
tell the difference between anything,
any of them.
Sorry.
Then if you have any questions to clerk
usually doesn't know the difference.
All the clerk has worked on the fucking
register and the floor and you can't
even get to them.
But for a limited time dollar shave club
is basically giving away their shit.
Shower, shave static kid
set to new members, um,
for only $5.
This start is set features a executive
razor in there, three trials,
size versions of the most popular products
that help you save so fresh and so
clean. And your first box you
will receive the shave butter
bodywash and one wipe
Charlies black lives.
You will also receive their executive
razor which includes their premium,
weighty handle.
Any focus set of cartridges after the
first box replacement cartridges are sent
for only a few bucks a month.
This offer is exclusively
available@dollarshaveclub.com
slash bar that's dollar
shave club.com/bar and
if you want a great gift,
give them a dollar shave club.
Oh what?
And if you want a great gift
given doll shape levels,
if that's what the fuck
we've been talking about.
Okay,
I going crazy here.
They got super simple gift
memberships in e Gift Cards,
dollar Shave Club's high quality products.
We'll have you covered from
face cheeks to butt cheeks.
There's no better time to try the club.
All right.
Oh look who's back?
Everybody me on beyond these no more
sweaty balls to do to to me undies.
Biondi you can't get a meadow malls
hacking up your head with Shitty fucking
blades.
Oh,
I'm in Florida in the everglades.
Alligators are getting eaten by fucking
snakes. I'm at the hard rock cafe and I,
every million every year,
millions of people received the
least like gift of all time.
The lease like gift of all
time. Cologne, no underwear.
But we still give it to our family and
our loved ones who just don't want it.
But maybe it's not the
underwear and that's approval.
It's the kind of the underwear.
It's the kind of underwear.
Let me tell you about me undies.
The only underwear that makes for an
amazing gift undies have a soft and
flexible waistband,
three times softer than cotton.
Naturally sustainable source
fiber me and he's made underwear.
The perfect get that gift that
everyone is going to love you for.
It's a God damn holiday miracle this year.
Don't give underwear.
Give me undies this holiday season to get
exclusive 20% off the soft assigned to
wear and socks you'll ever wear.
Free shipping a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com
that's m, e, u, N, d, I, e,
s.com/burr B. U. R. R.
Thank God it's over.
So when you live in a world,
in a world where everyone's sexually
harassing somebody and Newsweek as a
waterless earth on the carpet,
you gotta be asking yourself,
where do I go to get out
of this negative cloud?
Hmm?
Where do I go? Well, I swear to God,
I'm so sorry I wore my Invisalign.
I'm so sorry you had
to listen to my teeth.
Get a little straighter during
this her thing. Um, you know what?
I actually looked up positive
news and I found this thing,
the good news network,
man.
God Damn it.
If they don't have good news,
he lets you want it to say some positive
news here. Let's end on a positive note.
Good news in history, December
14th, on this day, 40 years ago,
Saturday night fever premiered
starring a young John Travolta.
Is it champion dancer with
all this date rape friends,
there's something positive.
I want to put my little negative
spin and all of this, uh,
burger king drive through worker goes
firewall after it helping a diabetic
woman. Well, what in the fuck
did he give her on the menu
or is that a her? I think
that might be, or her.
I think that's a,
her um,
guy shows you how to use Amazon prime
to instantly help the homeless. Okay.
There's some fucking advertising
laden as a positive fucking story.
Okay.
Needle free injections is,
it's just all fucking commercials.
That was a burger king commercial.
This isn't positive. Oh.
And a historic announcement.
World Bank says it will no longer finance,
oil and gas exploration.
Okay.
The bank is walking away from oil and
gas exploration and they're going to give
the oil companies the sun.
Okay.
All right.
The World Bank has just announced their
groundbreaking decision to cease all
investments in oil and gas exploration
over the course of the next two years.
This,
this can't be true in two years,
they're going to have no
money to drill for oil.
We're going to flip over to
fucking solar that quickly.
The announcement comes as a
welcome followup to the, you know,
it kind of helps if you're
reading positive news and
I'd have a negative cunt.
Fucking,
I like to think I'm more cynical.
Um,
see how,
see how much sugar is in honey
maple syrup and a Gavi nectar.
Mazda announces gasoline engine
using compression ignition.
Okay.
Why your pet looks like
you and vice versa.
How to pack light for easy travel.
Yeah.
I don't know what I, I don't know where
I am right now in the Internet, but, um,
I kinda like it. This is the system
kind of light news that I like.
Why does my pet look like me?
Speaking of which
Cleo,
who was in town this week,
I got to take three days in a row.
I got to take her on hikes
and I gotta tell you, man,
I still love that dog with all my heart.
But I,
I made the best decision of my life.
Uh,
she's now living with my
trainer who has to skills.
The dog has never been happier.
She's never looked more relaxed.
And for the first time in her life,
she's actually friends with another dog.
How amazing is that off leash,
you know, going up, you know,
smelling each other.
You know,
she's probably about a month and away
from laying in the sun with another dog,
just being happy as hell. And, um,
I wish I had the skill set to get
her there. God knows I didn't.
Thank God I did what I did.
And it's great that my trainer,
whenever he comes back to Los Angeles,
always brings her along and uh, it's
fucking awesome. It's really awesome.
I'm so happy for, although I still
miss her. I still miss that dog.
Um, anyways, but it had a happy ending.
Just like good news network.org.
MMM.
Okay. The announcement of the
World Bank comes as a week.
Welcome followup to the
financial institution's
decision to trop all investment
in the coal industry back in 2010 now,
after years of pressuring
from environmentalist,
the World Bank will draw up almost a
billion dollars in annual loans from oil
and gas groups. Well, this is just
a World Bank. It's not every bank,
so I'm sure chase and Wells Fargo will
gladly take that business that they just
dropped.
MMM.
Related News.
Alon must record breaking battery
was just switched on in Australia.
This'll be the tipping point.
This'll when, when, you know,
we're not going to have a fucking world
without water and we're just not going
to do it. Okay. I refuse to,
I can't walk around with a kid
thinking that that's going to happen.
What's going to happen is basically,
this is just a bad hundred
20 years or whatever,
where we went in a direction we
zigged when we should have zagged.
Nobody's fucking wrong.
All right.
Quit pointing fucking fingers
at different colored ties.
Let's all get on the same fucking page.
It's a great way to,
I dunno, I went the fuck. Do I know
what I'm going to, Goddamn scientist.
My whole thing is let's stop fucking
spending $1 billion a month to fight the
fucking, uh, the, our gang from the
little rascals over there. You know,
they're bankrupt in us. You get
over here, you go fucking Sola,
right? And then those
people, first of all,
you don't even need to bankrupt
isis to second. We leave that.
Just going to go back to killing
each other. Just like when Russia,
when Russia left fucking, when Russia
collapsed and they're literally nineties.
I'm really going on in Olympia. I really
don't know much about world history,
but when Russia left Eastern Europe
right after they collapsed and all those
people got their fucking freedom again.
And everyone's like, oh, this is great.
All these poor,
oppressed people they meet.
They picked up fights that I had never
heard of because my entire, you know,
that whole Bosnian Serbs,
that whole fucking horrific
thing that happened over there,
I guess that shit was going on. And then
Russia came in, they had a common enemy.
They will fight in Russia
for the whole time.
And then the second they leave they
started right back up with their Hatfield
and McCoys Shit, you know? So,
which is always good. A war is
always good. That's another,
it's a very pro environmental,
I actually know cause the light fucking
oil fields on fire and all of that shit.
Uh, I dunno, whatever.
There's some, something will
happen, something will happen.
We'll fix it up, you know? Or maybe not.
Robots will come along and
they'll kill enough. Enough of us,
you know,
is there any good news on
this website about robots?
You know what it's really going
to take to turn this shit around.
It's going to take people like Elon Musk
not saying this guy's a fucking saint.
All right.
I'm just hoping he has a better product.
They have to start bribing politicians
the way oil companies and banks too.
Right?
That's where they have to do.
They got to get the electric people
have to get the politicians on the take.
So when the OBAMAS and they're fucking,
um,
they're run as president when they go
around and they give their speeches,
you know, the big
payback fucking tour, uh,
they would actually go to these companies
instead of the fucking oil companies
and the big banks and all of that type
of shit. That's all it is there a day.
Did you hear what I just said?
People I just solved the world's pollution
problems or financial problems and
our energy crisis all in one.
Okay.
One minute string of sentences that
was not even remotely released,
uh,
researched.
Okay.
And that's what you should be coming here
for. I'm going to make you feel better.
I will. I'll give you good news, Dude.
By the way, my condolences
to Philadelphia Eagle fence.
All right.
I finally just watched that fucking
eagles rams game, which was absolutely,
it's just a great fucking game
and all these fucking assholes.
[inaudible] it felt no.
You know what it is. You weren't
really a fan. That's what it was. Okay.
And what happened was too many
of the fucking sex symbols,
the quarterbacks went down this year.
And I think that that's why the product
is going down. All right, Aaron Rodgers,
Andrew Luck.
Now Carson Wentz is out.
You really have to enjoy football to
watch all their backups come in and play.
And uh,
what's great about when they go down
and then you get to see like how good it
had coached too.
They have,
can he design a game plan that can
fucking deal with the fact like bill
Belicheck did when we had a Freddy fingers
there when fucking the fuck with that
guys. Phil Mutchnik
what? That was his name.
Now he went to Kansas City and everybody
was all excited, including Paul verse.
He's saying the guy was a franchise
quarterback and I was saying, dude,
he was driving a fucking Lamborghini.
He was driving a Lamborghini
and fucking a new England. Now,
now they just gave him a z 28 and it's
going to look the same way. He's gonna.
He's not gonna look the same.
The hell was the guy's name.
I want to say his first name was Carson.
Considering so many fucking people's
name, quarterback named Carson, who?
Carson Wentz out for the goddamn season.
I'm going to,
I'm going to retweet.
Did you guys hear that Eagle's fan call
the sports show and he started crying.
Just let go of your way.
There's no way bureau,
if you're a Boston sports fan,
you're like over the age of
like 40, you know? Exactly.
I remember I had a buddy of mine after
the Aaron Boone home run called up and he
was like in tears.
There's one year I didn't
want to see with it.
You too much. I mean, Jesus Christ.
Okay,
there you go.
26 championships,
right? Then all of a sudden it's always,
it's always darkest before the Dawn,
you know, and now look
at us now, we're now,
we're the fucking spoiled rich kids
with all the goddamn championships. So,
um,
okay.
I Dunno, I dunno what to
tell you, but I swear to God,
I'm really starting to
believe that Philadelphia,
Kansas City and San Diego,
like they built their stadiums on some
like ancient native American burial
ground or something. I,
there's no other way to explain
it and it really comes to,
it's not
okay.
Death they lose.
It's still way that they lose.
It reminds me of being like a red socks
patriots and all a Bruins fan growing
up. We had the Celtics, thank God, but
it was just like all of those teams,
they didn't have the decency to just suck.
They had to get right there.
And when everybody was watching and they
then they had too many men on the ice,
Bucky dent roughing the passer, you
know, whatever the fuck. You know,
our fucking bill Parcells announces
to the team before the Superbowl.
I'm not going to be back next year.
I'm selling my house that fat to an cunt.
Um, who by the way, never won
shit without bill Belichick.
Overrated under it. Overrated
bill. Parcells Oh, Bill,
you're going to get some shit on that one.
I don't think he's fucking overrated.
It just pissed me off that he had
a fucking goddamn temper tantrum
about that cause you know,
because the owner overruled them
and made them draft Terry Glenn,
rest his soul who they then,
then everywhere bill Parcells went
after he fucking brought Terry Glen.
But when he was in New England is a Gui.
You want me to cook the meal?
They go to buy the groceries.
Yeah.
Well from the looks of you eating
everybody else's fucking meal. Um,
anyways, plowing ahead here. Uh,
and I didn't fro Cleveland in there and
I won't throw Cleveland in there because
I don't have any sympathy for Cleveland
sports fans the way I don't have.
I'd never had sympathy for fucking cubs
fans just because everybody gives a shit
about you.
They're always doing stories about how
fucking sad you are. People give a fuck.
You know what I mean?
You like that little kid that fell down
and his mother was right there to hug
him and kiss him.
That's what Cleveland fans are.
Okay.
Nobody gives a fuck about Philly fan.
Somebody gives a shit about
what's going on in Kansas City.
Nobody gives a fuck about everything
that happened to the charger fans that
weather's perfect. Fuck them.
Nobody cares. And then the
team left. Nobody cares.
All right.
I love the browns.
I fucking, they fucked up
their uniform. So, and uh,
their quarterback has my, my favorite
quarterback name in the league right now.
The Sean Kaiser.
Okay.
African American, yet possibly a
Nazi. I mean, how do you beat that?
How'd he beat the duality of that?
Um, anyways, what am I do?
I think that's the end of
the podcast that I did.
I talk about everything that I want to
talk about. Oh, by the way, coming up,
I can't believe this.
This'll be my 10th rose bowl in a row.
I'm in double digits.
And if I keep going,
that means at some point when I die,
they're going to win.
I beat that old guy that they
announced, you know, and then
we went up 40 Shelburne
road bowls in a row.
Um, I was actually thinking
if I live to a hundred,
I'll have gone to 60 in a row or 61.
Okay.
Oh my God. How close to the fucking
stadium will I have to park?
We'll have to do you know,
you,
you're parked on a golf course still
literally have to send a golf cart out to
me. Um, and by the way,
I am really fighting, not going
off the wagon for one day that day.
I keep going back and forth.
Like I'll just go off one day,
one day I'll get fucking hammered.
And then I'm like, no, no, no, no, no.
Cause I wanna go,
I wanna go a whole calendar year.
January,
right through to December without booze.
And that would put me at 501 days. And
then next year's Rosebowl not this one.
The next one I would come off the wagon.
I Dunno what,
I have no idea. I haven't, I
haven't figured it out, but um,
yeah,
let's just put it this way.
I'm getting weak.
Hey, you guys let me know some good
MP, three players, if you don't mind.
Oh by the way, Santa
Steve Simone, Santa Steve,
Steve's Simone and regulate hero are
raising money again this year for children
fighting cancer and their families.
Monday morning podcasts.
Listeners help raise 15
grand last year around
last time around and it, I dunno if
though they just fucked up the set.
We raised 50 grand last year and had
a huge impact on a lot of families.
Their stories are brutal.
We're going to spare you this stories
and every little bit helps this goal.
The goal this year is we're
going to try to raise 50 grand a,
I'm going to tweet the link today.
Retweeted,
I should say thank you for everybody
who's been helping out. Um, all right.
Is that it? Oh, I never talked about
the Yankees Getting Giancarlo Stanton.
All right.
And I know what you guys are thinking.
I'm going to be frothing at the mouth
and we talking about Derek Jeter,
the front office. If the Patriots did
some shit like this, they'd waterboard us.
Fuck all that.
All right.
I still will always hate the Yankees,
but like,
I can't get mad at that fucking
move. All right. They've,
they're doing everything I
wished the red sox were doing.
They built from their own system.
They have a young team
that way over achieved.
I mean even without gene Carlisle,
I was like,
these guys are going to get
number 27 they got 26 to 26,
28 they're going to get number
28 within the next five years.
That's what I saw this year.
And now they added this guy and um,
basically that whole fucking team is
from their own system essentially.
Especially all their great players.
This guy became available and they went
out and got him. Who gives a fuck? My,
my team, the Red Sox, we've been
buying up the league forever.
Like the Yankees were like that fucking
person that your mother said don't hang
out with him.
He's a bad influence.
And then we secretly hung out with them
anyways and then we ended up doing what
they were doing.
Now we're hooked on the junk and they
went into fucking rehab but which still
strung out trying to fucking buy a
championship and they're building one old
school shit. And then they're
adding a there and a free agent.
I don't have a fucking problem with it.
And plus the fact that it came from
the Miami Marlins who their ownership,
I don't know if it's the
same one historically does
this puts together a good
team,
then they win a world series and then
they just dumped the whole fucking team
constantly fucking over the fence.
And I actually liked how I want us, Jean
Carlos Stanton was about it. So, uh,
and it's also, it's good when the
Yankees are good. Um, so I don't,
I don't have a problem with it. And, uh,
I don't think there was some sort
of collusion with, with Derek Jeter.
I don't think there was that, you know,
I don't think he's the main guy in there.
MMM.
And knowing him, I bet he was concerned,
like, this is going to make me look bad,
which never happened in his entire
fucking career. So he's probably thinking,
I don't need to start now.
I mean,
this isn't like when Kevin Mchale
sent Kevin Garnett to the Celtics.
I mean,
if I'm going to get mad at this.
And what about the Celtics in
2008 so what are you going to do?
That's how the fucking game was played up.
Sick of being a grumpy old man.
Congratulations to the Yankees
and you knew fucking guy.
But we now we gotta go buy somebody
that can strike out. You know?
You know what was funny though? Here's
my buddy versus he was like, oh,
the Yankees, he didn't see what
they did. They never disappoint.
This was the same guy flipping out when
Katie went to the fucking Golden State
Warriors.
It's a great move by the Yankees.
It's not good for baseball to
have a fucking MVP leaving Miami.
That's their guy.
He should've retired with them,
but you have to blame the fucking
ownership on that one. Um,
it seemed like he wanted to stay. I read
a great article where he was saying,
listen, I don't want to rebuild. I want
to move forward. Let's get some pitching.
We got a great fucking team.
And they were like, no, no.
We're just going to make money off of
people coming down to watch you hit home
runs as you lose fucking a hundred out
of 162 games. He was like, fuck that.
I'm out of here. So a good for him. Um,
all right. That's the fucking podcast.
Uh, or freckles is, um, 119 days in
and uh, he starting to get the
shakes here. This is a deal.
If I can just get past the
rose bowl, I think, uh, look,
I gotta go. I can't, six months is a good
time to stop, right? I'm four months in,
you know, I think I'm going to be,
I'm going to be doing a college tour.
We're trying to put this together in,
um,
in February,
you know,
I was going to start possibly the dream
is on this tour is to go to a Kansas
Jayhawks basketball game and it
Kentucky wildcat game start with Kansas.
So start with Kentucky and then in Kansas
or and in Kentucky, you know, book,
end them with Games. And, uh, I
was going to do an f is for family
college tour, you know, and hopefully
get a bunch of free swag, you know,
to fucking throw with the kids when
I go there. You know what I mean? Um,
that's the game plan.
That's what that one working out.
But if I did that then
I'd be road dog in it.
So we'd probably rent a bus and
then that would be hard. Oh,
that would be a hard one. So I don't
know if there's always those. Thanks.
There's always those times we shall
see. Um, all right, that's the podcast.
That Thursday afternoon podcasts.
I was just checking in on you.
Just see now you fucking weeks going a
happy Hanukkah to everybody and a happy
pre Christmas, merry Christmas.
Whatever the fuck I'm supposed to say.
Happy Kwanzaa.
Happy Ozark Day.
Whatever the fuck you say to people.
I have no idea. All right. Uh,
have a great weekend.
You can't enjoy the music and uh,
we'll have another half hour of a
greatest hits from a Thursday afternoon
podcast from a Thursday in a year gone
by or possibly, or the earlier this year.
Right?
I don't fucking know,
Eh.
Yeah.
Well,
as she
is my one
question,
so much time
bully, I can beat up. All right. Well
if there's a bully you can beat up.
He's not really a bully. He's just
an asshole. Right? Hey Billy boy,
I'm a 15 year old lad from
Australia and it's my problem.
There was a complete Dick
head at my school that always
picks on me. But here's,
here's the twist.
I could smash the shit out of this prick.
I'm 182 centimeters.
That's six feet tall,
fit 15 years old, six feet
tall. He goes 74 kilograms.
That's 160 pounds. Few people keeping
score and every other day what are,
and he's about five,
eight and weighs about 185 pounds.
All right, so he's got, he's got your
bike, he's got, you buy 25 pounds,
but you have the reach advantage. This is
the tale of the tape here. I love this.
You got a four inch reach advantage.
Unless he has those fucking Kevin Mchale
arms that are almost dragging on the
ground. All right, you go. I lift weights
every other day and he's just fat.
Okay.
All right. You're definitely
the favorite so far. He goes,
but this isn't the biggest
reason why I could smash this.
Can I have about 20 years
of martial arts experience?
Okay.
Wait a minute.
You're 15 years old.
How do you have 20 years of experience?
Okay.
Oh,
he's going to break it down.
I have about 20 years of martial arts
experience when you add it all up.
I have seven years in karate,
five years in movie tie. Oh,
Jesus. Dude, you bring those
fucking knees so that fat belly,
Oh my God. Probably got shins
like a fucking street pole. Um,
Street Pole, stop sign, whatever
the fuck I was trying to say.
I pictured a telephone pole and a
stop sign made out of metal fun.
I came up with St Paul. Look at
that. I'm inventing words here.
Seven years of karate,
five years of Muay Thai,
five years a Brazilian Jujitsu,
Jesus Christ, standing up,
go to the ground. What do you want
to dope? And three years of MMA,
he constantly calls me
name like gay boy and Poof.
And he slaps me in the back of the head
every day. Dude, you can't have that.
Uh, this has been happening for like
two months now and I haven't fought back
because I'm worried about getting in
trouble from teachers at martial arts
classes. Any advice as welcome?
Uh, thanks for whatever.
Whatever helps you. Uh,
whatever help you can give me.
Okay.
Go Fuck yourself and have a good day.
All right, sir. Well, this is the deal.
You could, or if you actually
applied what, you know,
you could seriously hurt this guy,
but you do have to defend yourself.
So is there a way that the next time
he goes to slap you in the head,
you can put them in one of those fucking,
those holds?
We're just holding the person's thumb
and they're all of a sudden on their
tiptoes going, all right. All right.
All right. All right. All right.
Is there a way to just shoot one across
the bow? That's what I'm suggesting.
I'm not saying that you fucked this kid
up and then ruin your standing with uh,
your, uh, your seafoods, your
Sensei's, your, your, your pastors,
whatever the fuck you call
them down at the Dojo. Um,
okay.
Yeah,
but there's no reason for you to go to
school and get slapped in the back of the
head and being called names.
Okay? So what I would do is, uh,
oh, what the fuck he asking me?
This is what you do. Jesus Christ.
Here's your solution. Talk to one of you,
your karate masters there and just say,
listen,
this is the deal.
I know after everything that you've
taught me that I could wish what?
Mop the floor with this fat tub of Shit,
but I don't want to get in, you know,
bad standing with you. What,
what do I do here? Have them,
have them tell you what
to do and cause they'll,
they could probably suggest they know
the name of whatever that fucking
had a choke out somebody's thumb.
Whatever that thing is that you guys
do that I wish I knew how to do. Um,
but here's the deal. One
way or the another. Uh,
there has to be a solution with this guy
slap and you this slapping you in the
back of the fucking head.
Um,
do you do, do you know how to do a death
grip yet? Have they taught you that?
Is that an actual thing?
Why don't you do a double death grip to
his man tits and twist them before he
has a chance to slap you in the head.
Don't listen to anything that
I'm going to suggest here. Uh,
why don't you take some Twinkies?
What,
what could you do with the
twinkie and a martial art thing?
Why don't you make some nunchuck
Twinkies and it says on,
instead of slapping them in the face
with the, with a piece of wood, it's a,
it's a twinkie and it goes across his
face. He's humiliated. Plus, you know,
he's a fatty,
so he's going to have to lick it off his
face and he'll get into that sugar rush
and his eyes will roll
in the back of his head.
And by the time his eyes come back down,
you're going to be across the room and
he can't slap you in the head out of,
there's gotta be something.
There's gotta be something to do.
Okay.
I mean, at this point, if you
don't want to go physical,
I would just go verbal. Oh,
I, you know, he's calling
you gay boy and poof. I mean,
why don't you just talk
about his fat tits.
Okay.
Just Act. Just be jazz used to
be really sincere. Just be like,
just out of curiosity, how much
do your tits way, you know,
do you wear a sports bra or are you
going to kind of go with the, uh,
the giant pocket tee?
Yeah.
And the fact that you're already
this fat and our young age,
like how fat do you think you're
going to be when you're 40?
And these are just
questions, sir. You know?
And then when he charges you like a rhino,
just step out of the way and he won't
be able to slow down and maybe go flying
into some desks. I don't know sir.
But can you please tell me how this I,
I w I would go, I would go to your,
uh, your Dojo masters there, whatever,
and I'd ask them what to do,
but there's no fucking way on any level
that you should have to tolerate that.
Uh,
okay.
Yeah, I would do that. Ah, Jesus.
Are they going to go even
really more mature? Well,
I think you should talk to your teachers
about it and then you become the
fucking guy ratted out. Yeah, I like that.
It's a selection that's like this, uh,
solutions they come up
to on like the view.
You just turn around and you
just face, stop doing that. I, I,
I'm not going to tolerate this.
You know,
I'll give you like a rape whistle
or something. I don't fucking know.
I don't know,
sir.
But please let me know how that works
out because it's bothering me that,
that dude is doing that to you. All
right. I don't like bullies. Um,
oh Jesus Christ. Do you know what
I really want to tell you to do?
And I'm not good.
Jeez.
I've been with my boyfriend
for two years now.
We're in college together
and he's currently taking a
semester abroad. Oh Jesus.
Where in Brazil?
Before he left,
we had a running joke that I was going
to need a vibrator when he left as a
surprise party gift.
He got me one.
I have a couple of friends whose
boyfriends bought them sex toys.
So while I was a little surprised,
he actually got me a vibrator.
I also happen to know that
it's a relatively normal,
it's relatively normal for a
boyfriend and do that. Yeah.
That's basically like this
era's chastity belt. You know,
you're trying to lock down the pussy.
That's disgusting.
But that's what he's doing now anyway.
Yeah. But it's done because those things,
you use them too much.
They numb up your area there and then
the guy can't even remotely try and,
you know,
do something for her and then you
gotta be sitting there banging,
banging them as their user.
We're using the thing as you know,
it's like you want an alien
or fucking this girl has this.
That's just all dick has no body.
All right, whatever. Let's move on.
What I'm basing it on
based on my fucking life,
I did live a little bit of a life before
I met you. I realize that. All right.
Any way, fast forward to about a
week ago, we were on Skype. Uh,
he asked you to take this thing out. Um,
no, we don't have sex chats. Thank God.
And he casually asked me how
his gift for me was working out.
I told them it was
working out pretty well.
He then mentioned that he had
bought something for himself,
a flashlight.
Joe Rogan experience is brought to
you by the fleshlight every week.
He does every very weird,
those are very gay.
They look like that thing.
Boba Fett I fell into when he died
and one of those space movies. Okay.
Wow. Um, I knew how to be faithful
to her. That's nice. Okay.
He said,
she goes,
I knew what this was because I am an
avid listener of Joe Rogan's podcast.
How you doing?
Joe Robbins come up three times in this
podcast who raves about it constantly.
My boyfriend had never mentioned to me
that he was interested in anything like
that and I always thought the
idea of it was totally creepy.
I acted like it was totally cool,
but in all honesty,
I really don't want him to be
fucking a perfect fake wait,
I got lost in that.
I actually was thinking,
is Joe going to get mad that I'm
saying that this is weird? Okay.
I acted like it was totally cool,
but in all honesty,
I really don't want them to be fucking
of perfect fake vagina whenever he wants
to.
I'm finding myself getting crazy jealous
and angry whenever I think about it.
I know, I know I'm jealous of an
inanimate object, which seems insane.
Let me finish.
I'm really struggling with this because
part of me wants to be completely okay
with it since it's sort of a hypocrite.
It's sort of hypocritical to get
angry when he got me a vibrator.
But now I'm starting to think that maybe
he only bought me a Dildo so I wouldn't
be able to complete when he
got himself a proxy pussy,
Pussy.
So what do you think?
Do I need to suck it up and get over
this or is my jealousy legitimate?
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
Go fuck is fake pussy.
As long as he's not faking a real buzzy,
I mean fucking a real policy
then you know it's all good.
Plus you. It's not just like
the the pussy that it's,
that he's missing.
He's also missing like,
you know your touch and kissing
and the whole other part of it too.
And that fake pussy cat low.
Am I there? No, he isn't.
He's getting right to the dessert.
Don't be Japanese.
Tried these Brussels sprouts.
Don't need them. Don't be jealous.
I bring over the trace Lecce when he
comes back it will be even better because
you both have been like doing it with
anatomy and objects and so it's, I don't,
you'll be rediscovering each other
all over again. I'll be even better.
I don't think. We don't even
worry. I don't think it's a
good thing. Why? Because,
uh,
once you start down a path sexually,
you know,
in order to get off that path,
you don't just jump
over onto another path.
You've got to walk all the way
back up the path you went down,
get to the fork where you fucked up
and then head down the other one.
What I'm saying is he might get used
to just doing that and the sensation of
that is what gets him off.
And then when her pussy doesn't feel
like the fleshlight Hillary don't feel
better, he'll, he'll
build bang her and then,
and then when he needs to finish, he'll
be like, oh, hi. And now for me, hey can,
can't take a day.
What that fucking yeah,
no, no. She'll fall even better. If
anything, he'll be like, oh my God,
I forgot what a real woman feels like
and he'll be done in like two minutes.
That's what you hope.
I don't think she should be
jealous of it though. They're both,
they're both doing the right thing.
When you're in a relationship and you're
that far apart from each other because
he took,
I bang all sorts of Harry European girls,
no offense to Harry European girls,
but I'm just saying, you know, listen,
I watched this thing one time or
listen to it on the radio. Uh,
one of those Colin's sex shows
and this guy had a pull away.
He jerked off. I see dry hump, the rug,
it was causing like chafing on
his deck and it, but it, it,
it was the only way he could get off
because he wasn't in a relationship for a
while and he kept doing that. And
I dunno. So I'm just saying like,
I would go easy on those.
It's like anything, anything
in moderation. Yeah. How,
how often is he using this and
how often is she using that?
If use a vibrate too much,
you're numb yourself up down there.
And then when you guys
down there, I, Daddy,
I can't feel anything.
That's so disgusting.
Jeez.
Six.